so today we're going to be looking at
different ways of doing autofocus with a
camera so when you're taking a photo
with any kind of camera really so a lot
of phones or definitely things like SLRs
like this you might see an autofocus
mechanism so here we've got MF the
manual focus and AF for auto focus so if
we've got it set on auto focus
essentially the camera and these days
the computer inside the camera decides
whether a picture is is blurry or not
and corrects that by moving the lens so
we're going to look at a few of the the
methods you can do that okay so let's
start back in the day so the first kinds
of focus assists I suppose you could
call it so back in the sort of run about
the 1930s there was something called the
rangefinder cameras came out these are
cameras that have a sort of extra
separate mechanism on the side of them
which was the rangefinder mechanism now
this was all done with optics and the
way it works is you basically see a
viewpoint of what you're looking at and
then you get a kind of like a ghost
image that's shifted to one side
normally what you have to do is change a
dial on the rangefinder mechanism to
bring the two images kind of lying on
top of each other so these days it's all
kind of joined into the imaging system
so generally speaking there's two
different ways you can do autofocus
there's active methods and there's
passive methods so an active method will
fire something out from the camera and
it will use that to work out how far
away something is so some of the most
some of the earliest mechanisms for
doing active autofocus used something a
bit like sonar so it would send out a
ping from the camera and it would
basically time how long it took to hit
something and bounce back just like the
way sonar works and it would use that to
work out a distance that you could then
use to focus it so you can use sound you
can also use light so some active
systems will fire out light from the
camera what we're actually going to
concentrate on today is the passive
approaches how do we actually focus a
camera when we're not sending out light
or sound so we're just using
the light that's coming into the lens to
do the focusing one of the most popular
passive mechanisms of autofocus is
something called phase detection so you
might be aware of phase detection
systems on your camera you might have
different autofocus points different
areas of an image that you can choose to
focus on let's have a look at how phase
detection works in each one of those
regions with a phase detection system if
this is our lens coming into the camera
what we do is we essentially measure how
light behaves at different points on the
lens so if we have a ray coming from
here and we sort of follow it through so
I'm not going to draw all the
complicated optics here your light rays
that go through the lens fall upon an
autofocus sensor so this is really
essentially a sort of 1d strip of
photodiode so set of pixels essentially
it's like a little image sensor that the
light hits here now the trick behind
phase detection is you measure two pars
of light so you would actually have a
second sensor so this second light ray
here actually hits a different sensor
imagine behind-the-scenes that this is
separated by optics but just to kind of
simplify things let's draw what's
happening here so what we get hitting
this set of pixels if you like is we get
to see one of the image features in the
image so if we've got a very simple
image what we might have here is a
little peak so perhaps the edge of
something at one of those detection
points and because in this case the
image is well focused these two curves
will overlay if you imagine our two
images hitting our autofocus sensor and
they're perfectly aligned in the case
where the image isn't in focus what
happens is these beams go through the
pixels like this and they actually focus
just behind the pixels so what that
means is if we draw our curves we have
one peak that's kind of up here like
this and we have another peak that's a
little bit below like this because we're
not in focus so the nice thing about
phase detection is that what you do is
you measure the offset
these two peaks and the distance between
them tells you how out-of-focus they are
so let's just draw the last case where
so this one is kind of focused past the
sensor and the other way that you can be
focused is in front of the sensor so we
have light coming up here and perhaps
doing something like that so our focus
point is here so when it hits the
autofocus sensors they're going to be
offset again so the two sensors will
give a reading of one kind of curve up
here and one curve down here not drawn
very well okay and then we get another
distance out what these sensors do so
remember in reality there's probably two
of these inside the system that the
lights hitting this is a very simple
image that we're making here in practice
the two curves might be quite
complicated you know there might be
different features that we see they're
not just going to be a straight Peterson
at a time it would be some kind of
pattern of light that's hitting these
sensors and so the job of the phase
detection mechanism is to work out how
to move one of these curves so that it
lines up with the other one so
mathematically you can do something
called cross correlation there which is
a way of essentially looking at how to
best match two signals that are offset
from each other and what that gives you
is a distance and it's that distance
that phase detection uses to drive the
lens so the nice thing about phase
detection is that once it's calculated
this distance is very fast to focus
because not only does it know it's out
of focus but it knows by how much so
once it's calculated this difference it
can say to the to the mechanism driving
the focus lens okay move this much in
this direction so we've got a distance
but we also know whether we focus too
far away or focus too close because if
you notice here the red peak here is
above the green peak when we focus
behind and here the green peak is above
the red beet when we're focused in front
by knowing which way to shift these
patterns it knows how far to move the
lens on which direction so phase
detection tends to be one of the
quickest ways to focus a camera but in
most systems use this color key or de
mostest so a lot of systems will use
both so a lot of SLRs will use both and
the reason is
when you're focusing through the
viewfinder it tends to use phase
detection because it's using the optics
of the the lens system to steal a bit of
the light and pass it to these sort of
pairs of autofocus sensors so you gets a
one pair for each autofocus region but
you can only do that when you're looking
through the viewfinder if you open the
live view so that changes how the optics
in the camera works and so then it will
tend to use a process called contrast
detection which we'll look at now now
contrast detection does work on light
that's hitting the imaging sensor so
we're not using the optics in here to
divert light around to the autofocus
sensors this is just using the sensor
that is essentially used to capture the
final image what we're going to be doing
is reading off some values of those
pixels that make up your image and one
of the things one of the properties
about focus is that the contrast of the
image so sort of the differences between
the the bright bits and the dark beers
get more extreme the more InFocus you
are so when you have nice crisp focus
you get nice clear differences between
black areas and white areas so what that
means is if we have a way of calculating
those differences so how kind of sharp
our edges are and our corners are and
how different our regions of light and
dark are so we can measure our contrast
we can kind of work out how in focus we
are so if we just work through how we
would do that using a really simple
example we can look at some other kind
of gotchas that happen on the way and
think about why it's quite slow to do
this as well so we've got a photograph
here which I've just turned black and
white because it just makes the
processing a bit simpler so we're just
using a tool here called image j which
allows us to do some pretty simple
scripting just to get our pixel values
and to blur the images as well you can
just download this and try stuff out
what's going on here is we can get the
values of the pixels and in order to
work out how much contrast we have in
the image probably the very simplest
thing we can do is just look at pairs of
pixels and calculate the difference
between them in terms of brightness so
if we just go through an image a pair of
pixels at a time and calculate the
difference between them when we kind of
maximize that the total of all those
differences then we are in pretty good
focus because we got the most contrast
we can have so that's what this simple
example here will do and this line here
is just calculating the difference
between them so I'm just calculating
differences in the x-direction so in the
row along here some times and this is
true with phase detection as well your
calculations of contrast or phase can
either be sort of in the X direction
along the rows or along the columns or
you can get sort of cross sensors that
do both in phase detection in the
contrast here we're just going to do
neighboring X pixels okay so we could
calculate all the neighboring Y pixels
as well but just to keep it simple on
doing this we could use probably a
better measure of contrast so something
like a Sibel operator or something else
that's good for detecting edges but just
as a very simple example let's just
measure the difference between
neighboring pixels and see how that
changes as we go out of focus which I'll
simulate by blurring the image so if I
run this it will move over the image it
takes a little while because I'm moving
across all the pixels we get a number
here which is essentially the total of
all those differences between the pairs
of pixels so it doesn't really matter
absolutely what the number is what we're
going to do is try and find the peak
okay if these these values so actually
we're starting off in focus here and
we've got a value of about 5 million
let's make it a little bit out of focus
so if we apply a Gaussian blur so I
don't know whether you can see there but
it's gonna be our focus there you can
see we've lost our crisp edges so if I
run this again being a little bit out of
focus taking a little while to go over
it so our first value was 5.1 million
we've now got a value of 1.2 million so
we've gone from 5 million down to 1
million
as the total of our differences so we've
gone about our focus and we've got a
lower contrast value if you like so
let's take it to the extreme case
terribly our focus image right my
comment so run it again there we are so
now we've gone from 1.2 million down to
145,000 and if we take it to the extreme
the real extreme case we're going to get
very low values coming out here so
what's happening if we have an algorithm
that does this is that we can plot these
values on a curve
so if this is our focus motor driving
the lens and this is our measure of
contrast which in this case is just
differences in pairs of pixels what's
going to happen is we're going to get
some kind of curve like this so when
we're out to focus either way the value
is going to drop down like it does there
when we're in focus we're kind of at
this peak point here so the trick with
contrast detection is finding this peak
with my camera operator head-on looking
at the shot I'm looking at now I've got
the laptop quite close to me yeah I've
got you in the middle and I've got the
blinds at the back yeah and experience
tells me that autofocus will look at
those blinds and go hey they're nice
they're going to look great if they're
and you're gonna be blurry in your face
yeah so that can be a problem if you're
running this over a whole image you're
gonna get issues so quite often for
example on your phone you can you can
essentially select a region to focus on
so you can press a region on your phone
or you can select a focus point on Live
View or something like that
well that will do is it will only
calculate this difference across a
particular region of an image so if we
just want to focus on the library here
we can just calculate this over there
otherwise you're right it's going to end
up kind of optimizing this curve for
something in the image that you might
not care about the shiny stuff shiny
stuff and of course the other thing to
say I suppose is we've gone through
every pixel in the image here but
actually you would probably only sort of
subsample the image in order to make it
quicker you might have noticed it took a
little while to work
these methods tend to be quite slow
they're not as slow as this because
they're not calculating every single
pixel you don't generally need to but
the catch with this method is that you
can tell you're out of focus so when we
were out of focus that sort of 1.2
million on our counts of down here if
this is 5 million where we were to start
with and then the first time we blurred
it we went down to 1.2 million we know
we're here but we don't know whether
we're there or there so we don't know
which way to move the lens you will
notice when cameras used this as a
hunting mechanism so it has to move the
lens a little bit and work out whether
it's got better or worse so or tend to
move it in quite big jumps like this and
as soon as it starts getting worse it
will kind of hunt back so you get these
steps moving up the curve to try and
find the sort of optimal focus point up
here so you need to search so that's one
of the reasons why contrast detection is
pretty slow
unlike face detection where it says move
this much in this direction move the
lens this much in this direction to
focus with contrast detection you don't
get that you just say I'm out focused
but I don't know whether I'm too far
away or too close the other reason why
this method can fail is if it doesn't
have anything to measure contrast on to
start with so you need some kind of
texture so if you'll try and focus on
the sky region for example up here you
can imagine that even you know the more
and more I blur the sky it's not having
that much effect on the focus that's
pretty true of the phase detection as
well so if you've got no edges visible
it's very hard to do that pattern
matching to work out where you need to
move sometimes you you'll see things
like these charts which provide a nice
contrast between black and white edges
that use to assist the camera focus
focusing mechanism and the nice thing
about the calibration charts like this
so they have very good contrast bright
areas and dark areas that make focusing
a nice and easy so as an example let's
try perhaps focusing on this and taking
some out focus images and we can see how
the contrast focusing mechanism performs
as we go in and our folk
nice to focus let's see okay so you
might notice with your cameras that both
of these mechanisms will fail to work
very well when you haven't got much
texture so if you're pointing just at
the white wall there it's going to
struggle to find focus low-light is a
problem so you often get an assist beam
so some cameras will use a flash to
light up the scene so they can see what
it's doing some will send out they'll
have a little extra bulb that they light
up the scene with which could be done in
infrared so you can't see it and then it
could focus in infrared yes you get that
problem as well some systems will even
project out some kind of structured
light so like a grid of light or a
texture of light just to help these
algorithms focus a bit better so one
advantage of the of the active methods
is of course they'll focus in complete
darkness because if you're using sonar
it will bounce back off the wall whether
it's lit up or not the disadvantage
being it will bounce back from a window
as well so you can take photos through
glass and things like that so this kind
of swings and roundabouts with all these
different mechanisms to kind of
summarize the last two methods that
we've talked about the phase detection
is nice and quick but it needs its own
optics to work the contrast detection
works without fancy optics and it works
on a live view where you can just see
the image but it's a bit slower because
you have to do this hunting approach so
wouldn't it be nice if we could do some
kind of phase detection but on the
actual image sensor and so there's some
technologies coming along now so things
like dual pixel focusing where what
they've tried to do is essentially bury
these autofocus points throughout the
sensor so I think it's Canon that do
this approach I don't know if there's
other approaches available and the way
it works essentially each pixel is
comprised of two photo diodes so they
kind of work in pairs and each one of
the photo diodes has some kind of micro
lens attached to it you've got optics
going on but it's spread out across the
sensor and each one of these pairs of
photo diodes is used to do phase
detection focusing so it works on the on
the back main image
so the same one that's used to capture
the image so you use the pair of
photodiodes hence dual pixel to do the
essentially it's like phase difference
phase detection focusing but when you
want to take the picture both of the
photo diodes will work together to act
as a pixel to take the picture so the
nice thing about that is it's still
working on the backplane so when you're
looking at the LCD panel it's still
doing phase detection so it's it's nice
and fast
this is called the aperture problem or
the barbershop pole illusion because
it's got stripes moving up and down and
the idea being that there's not enough
information here to to accurate osteo
row times 100 plus y or x times 1 and
that will give you the exact point in
memory linear memory